Voiceover: So in the last few videos
we've essentially done an overview
of Benjamin Franklin's entire life,
and if people want to go more in depth,
there's a very good biography,
which I encourage people to read.
Actually it is fascinating.
You know just big picture takeaways,
what are the lessons from Ben Franklin?
Voiceover: Well first of
all he was a renaissance man
of the enlightenment, which was cool.
He loved science as well as
writing and the humanities.
He was our best scientist,
inventor, diplomat.
He was a good business strategist.
The first rags to riches person.
He's also the person who invents, I think,
the essential American character,
which is being proudly middle class,
being proud to be a shop
keeper as he put it,
a member of the Leather Apron Club
who gets up every morning,
puts on the leather apron,
and helps fellow citizens.
He also knew that the backbone of America
was going to be a shopkeeping class
who formed civic organizations
that brought people together.
That's why he forms all these things
like the libraries and the hospitals
and the academies and that sort of thing,
and also he has a notion of tolerance.
We were very ethnic people in the colonies
up until Philadelphia rises,
and Philadelphia is the first
city that has everything
from Anglicans and Moravians and Jews
and Quakers and freed slaves and Indians,
and Franklin is a shopkeeper
who becomes an apostle of tolerance,
saying if we help bring people together.
and tolerate everybody's beliefs
and religions and backgrounds,
that's going to be the secret
source of America's diversity.
You see it throughout his life.
You need wonderful passionate people
like John and Sam Adams if you're going
to have a great country,
and you need revered people
like George Washington,
but you also need the people who say,
"Our strength will come
from bringing us together,
"from our diversity."
Over and over again, when he creates
a civic organization the
motto will be things like,
"The good we can do together is greater
than all the goods we can do separately."
and, "To pull forth benefits
for the common good is divine."
That's engraved on the hospital.
He does his first editorial
cartoon called "Join or Die,"
which was about the colonies.
They all have to get
together and join or die.
When he goes to Albany in the 1750s
to bring the colonies
together so that they
aren't sort of a Catholic
colony of Maryland
and a Puritan colony of Massachusetts.
We're all one country
but religiously diverse.
Finally I'll go to the end of his life,
because it seems symbolic at that time,
after he brings people together
at the Constitutional
Convention and everything else,
I realize that during his lifetime,
he donated to the building fund
of each and every church
built in Philadelphia.
At one point they were building a new hall
during the Great Awakening,
when preachers used to ride
around America and preach,
and they wanted a hall in Philadelphia
that a visiting preacher could preach at,
and Benjamin Franklin writes
a fundraising document.
It says, "Even if the Mufti
of Constantinople were
"to send somebody to preach Islam to us
"and to teach us about
the prophet Muhammad,
"we should offer a pulpit and listen
"for we may learn something."
Voiceover: This is in
17? Back then, you know.
Voiceover: Yes this is
in the 1760s, 1770s.
He's very religiously tolerant.
On his death bed, I looked
at the ledgers of this,
he's the largest individual contributor
to the Mickve Israel Synagogue,
the first synagogue built in Philadelphia.
So when he dies,
instead of his minister
accompanying his casket to the grave,
all 35 ministers, preachers, and priests
of Philadelphia linked arms
with the rabbi of the Jews
for this huge funeral procession
that marched with him to the grave.
It was that type of tolerance, freedom,
belief that we could all live together
despite our different backgrounds
that was what they were fighting for,
what they created in 1776 and in 1787
when they create the United States,
and it is still the essential thing
that the United States is fighting for
both around the world but also at home
to keep that legacy of Ben Franklin alive.